And I did so for two reasons. Um, one
because there's a threat to my family.
Uh, the Israeli government and Netanyahu
himself tried to punish two members of
my family. I won't be more specific, but
actually punished two members of my
family.
We are teaching people how to pray
step-by-step. With Salah instructors,
guided Salah mats, and resources.
[music] And every time they pray, you
get to share in that reward. And when
they teach their children and their
children's children
the reward continues. Every Fajr Dhuhr
Asr Maghrib Isha Tarawih Tahajjud Every
recitation you share in the reward. For
just £100 you can help teach 20 to 60
people
>> like me learn how to pray Salah. Donate
today. Donate today. Donate today.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends.
Candace Owens, and I'm trying to find
this clip, hopefully if I find I'll put
it in this video, she said the
following, and it is coming to reality
to this day. They call it conspiracy
theories and all this kind of stuff.
Tucker Carlson's family is at risk now.
He's risk, their life is in danger. He's
made this very clear. He went to Israel,
and everyone was saying, "Why is he
going to Israel? Why is he going to
Israel? Is he compromised? Is it
something?" He had to go there for two
reasons, which you're going to find out.
Candace Owens, in a clip, said "Today
they are killing the children of Gaza,
the innocent Palestinians.
Tomorrow they're going to come to your
for your children. Your children, your
American children. Yes, they're going to
come for your children."
And that's exactly what's happening.
Look at what Tucker uh Carlson had to
say. Listen carefully. We pushed hard
for this meeting, and I called a lot of
people who know him and who are in
regular contact with him. In fact, I
went to go see some of those people
directly. Please, can you help me
get a sit-down for 5 minutes with
Benjamin Netanyahu? And I probably
called or met with six, seven, eight,
maybe more people on this question.
People in official capacities, people in
the Israeli government I know a number
of people in the Israeli government,
people in Israel, a friend of mine in
California who knows him. I mean, I
really really
>> Okay, why is Tucker Carlson desperately
trying to meet Benjamin Netanyahu? Why?
Now, number one,
it's not going to happen because he
knows exactly his stance and he knows
he's going to get absolutely
annihilated. But, why is he adamantly
trying to meet him?
Watch this now.
And I did so for two reasons. Um one,
because there was a threat to my family.
Uh the Israeli government and Netanyahu
himself tried to punish two members of
my family. I won't be more specific, but
actually punished two members of my
family.
>> Okay, interesting. Just just just
imagine this. Just imagine Muhammad bin
Salman, the ruler of
the Muslim lands is a caliphate, and he
commits a massive a genocide against the
Christians. And then you've got
journalists in America, yes, who are
speaking out against whatever it is, and
then their life is in danger. He had to
travel to Israel for two reasons. One
was to meet him. I think the
the first thing was for his family. His
family. Can you imagine American
journalists? Man, is this how bad you
guys are owned? Is Is as if um Israel
owns you. Like, you are owned. You're
the slave. Yes, You are owned by
them. And their lives are in danger.
They're risking their lives.
Because he has he has said in public
many times believes in blood guilt,
Amalek. You know, when someone commits a
crime against you, you punish not just
him, but his family, his bloodline.
There's no idea that's less Western than
that, more anti-Christian than that.
There you go. Now,
the Israeli Zionists are quoting
scripture, enacting scripture, so much
so that Carl Tucker Carlson is saying
now
that they kind of do the same with the
meaning, exactly what Can this Owen
said. They're going to come for your
children tomorrow, the American
children. And they're already doing it
by the island, taking them and doing all
kinds of griping and all that kind of
stuff there. They are coming for your
children. He's now saying they quote
Amalek. Meaning, they're coming for
Tucker Carlson's genealogy, bro. They're
trying to wipe his genealogy. Yes,
subhanallah. And that's what they're
known for.
And they are warning him. Look at this.
This is This is crazy, man. This should
be global average. Christians reject
that.
Um Netanyahu doesn't. That's why he's
talking about Amalek and he was going
after my family, literally. Uh so, I
felt very threatened by that.
But moreover, I Look, this guy has to go
to Israel, which his life could be at
risk. Bro, he could have died in an
accident. He could have just fell over,
got hit by a car, you know, a crazy
driver.
He risked his life for his family. This
makes sense why he had to go there. He
needs to make this public. Subhanallah,
they went they took out um
Charlie Kirk. They took him out. The
moment he turned they took Can you
imagine American journalists being
assassinated, threatened, annihilated
because they speaking the truth?
And you think they're not going to come
for you next? They're coming for all of
you. I think it's bad for my country
to have people using that kind of
language. Round them up, bring them to
the camps, gas chambers, Nazis,
anti-Semitism. It scares the heck out of
people, makes people crazy and
hysterical. And certainly in my case,
none of that is true. I hate collective
punishment. I hate
attacking people on the basis of their
bloodline. I hate anti-Semitism and
anti-white racism and all of the Anyone
with a decent human human being will say
that it is wrong to do collective
punishment.
They are not just doing it on the
Palestinians, they are now trying to do
it
on
these guys. Okay? And there's a whole
thing about, you know, Charlie Kirk's
maybe they will wipe out their
genealogy, but now they're saying Erica
Kirk we don't even know if the kids
belong to Charlie Kirk.
I don't any kind of racism, period. And
I've said that a lot.
So, using that kind of language against
someone who is not fundamentally your
enemy, who just in my case
I want Christians in areas controlled by
Israel to be treated with dignity, to
have rights,
and I don't
>> He's asking you to not kill innocent
men, women, children. And for the
Christian you're now you're saying that
we're funding you, you know, apparently
funding you, and stop persecuting
Christians in the holy lands. Yes?
Muslims protected them for centuries and
they lived in peace and harmony. Muslims
brought and protected them. But look
what they are doing to them. want the US
government involved in a war, a regime
change war with Iran. Those are my
priorities and I've said them out loud.
I have no secret agenda.
>> I mean this is crazy. Look at the way he
looks like he's like in a desperate
situation where he's like listen, I'm
not your enemy.
I'm just saying, you know, just just
don't do certain stuff. Like he's so
scared. He's like look, that's all I
wanted from and now you're coming after
me.
Wake up.
Can this Owens call this out? I wish I
can find that clip. Can this Owens call
this out? And today you see the reality
of Tucker Carlson's family members being
punished.
Being punished. And you've got American
um uh
senate senators
in the parliament, whatever whatever it
is for the government, are literally
saying yeah, like we're we're slaves to
them. They are the land was promised to
them. They're actually they're holy.
It's like they're holy. It's like they
worship They It's like It's like they
don't worship Jesus. They worship this
law.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable my sisters in
Shallah. Uh Subhanallah, share this far
and wide. Every Muslim should be clued
up and know what's going on. This is
unbelievable. Now they are coming for
the American journalists.
What can you say? So next time,
assalamualaikum warahmatullah hi
wabarakatuh.